for more information on tutoring
personalized video solutions or how to
support move university and the
production of more videos check out moof
university comm thank you and enjoy okay
so in this video just a few more things
about biotin we already mentioned that
buyouts and transfers carboxyl groups
and carboxylation reactions right so
we're transferring a 1 a 1 carbon group
that's specifically co2 which is most
oxidized or the least reduced a 1 carbon
group can be so this here is the
structure of biotin and biotin is
specifically vitamin b7 and during the
course of the reaction you'll notice
this little purple dotted box here that
portion of the molecule is pretty much
the most important part we start off
with biotin in this form and it's going
to grab the carboxyl group to be donated
right the the carbon dioxide and it's
going to attach at that portion of the
molecule there so we'll have that
carboxyl group and that will create
basically a carboxylated bias and that
carboxylated biotin is what actually
gives up that that that carboxyl group
to another molecule and when it does
that it regenerates biotin in the form
that we started with so the reaction can
happen again so that's basically it for
biotin I hope that video is helpful
thank you for watching if you found that
video helpful don't forget to like
comment subscribe and share with friends
thank you and happy studying